what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest developments in the attack on
titan story
and this is the second last chapter ever
and it was crazier than you could have
ever
imagined so many insane twists and
reveals
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan videos and want to keep them
coming
make sure the warhammer smash that like
button until it's blue
and subscribe with the notification bell
so you know the second the last chapter
review comes out
and while you wait a whole month for the
last chapter to drop
feel free to check out our colossal
attack on titan playlist
with videos about all time shifters and
their powers all ackerman's the times
running from weakest to strongest and
much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into this insane chapter
spoilers and all this chapter is called
a long dream and we'll get more into
that later
again we see a baby and babies can serve
as a symbol for the future
this little guy is left along with many
others as the colossal titans have
stopped moving
and are falling down and this is
happening since aaron has been separated
from the centipede creature
the rumbling has been stopped and the
remaining world is saved
or at least that's how it seems at this
point but with itayama
you can never be too sure we see falco's
flying titan again
and they watch as the bones of aaron's
giant skeletal titan disappear
mikasa's head is aching again she's
reminded of when aaron called ackerman
slaves with no free will
and he told her he always hated her
mikasa does want to accept that that
will be one of the last things he said
to her face
she doesn't want to leave it at that i'm
hoping we will learn more about mikasa's
headaches before
the story is over what aaron told mikasa
which i don't believe
is that once an ackerman awakens they
often suffer from sudden headaches and
that this happens out of the true self
trying to resist
being forced to protect the host
according to what he said the rio mikasa
disappeared in that mountain cabin
at 9 years old leaving a slave to
ackermann instincts behind
there's still so much that i feel like
we have to learn about the ackermans
for now though we move on to what could
be a happy-ish ending
all things considered many are reunited
with their parents and families like
gabby
pique falco and even annie eventually
but we'll get to that
the survey corps has their regrets but
they're happy they managed to stop the
rumbling
reiner in the meantime is still fighting
the shiny centipede creature
that started all this in the first place
when it attached to emir fritz about 2
000 years ago armin's in his colossal
titan reiner is beat up but not that as
usual
the plot armored titan is going strong
and still the centipede creature is not
dead after the explosion either
it's still struggling for survival and
it will be interesting to see how long
this creature can survive outside of the
founding titan host
as we may have guessed aaron isn't dead
even jon says he knew it he transforms
into his own
colossally sized titan body while
maintaining his signature long hair
so he could match up well with his old
best friend the current colossal titan
user
gabby tells them to keep aaron away from
the shiny centipede
or else the rumbling could start again
and while everyone is wondering how they
could kill the centipede creature that
survived
an explosion levi replies that aaron
might be the key
the nightmare won't finish until they
kill aaron our protagonist
how insane and dark is this for a series
that is classified as a shonen it's
crazy mikasa's head is still aching as
she wonders why things have to end this
way
in the meantime as aaron is preparing to
face off against armin the titan
centipede unleashes some gas
and oh man it is not a good sign we see
annie's dad
talking to a marleian as he says and i
quote we've made enough mistakes
let's take care of this together end
quote and annie's father agrees before
he comes face to face with his long-lost
daughter now the idea of a common enemy
to rally around is nothing new to attack
on titan
in fact the founding titans until grisha
and aaron believed that fear of titans
was the only path to any lasting peace
however another quote from this series
is that peace between men will never be
certain
not until our numbers fall to one or
less end quote
so can aaron hope that he made the world
suffer enough already
for lasting peace to occur in a pain
from naruto kind of way
perhaps i mean it's pretty clear now
that ldn's helped to stop him
and save the world and it definitely
brought the two sides together for now
but as was mentioned before as long as
there's more than one human alive
that peace can never be certain as
humans as long as there's more than one
of us left alive all we can do is trust
hope and try again
but back to the long awaited reunion
with annie and her father
unfortunately before they can even hug
the smoke from the creature has made it
to them we
jump to levi and the others on the
flying titan and he makes sure they all
get on
including peak so they can get out of
here as he says ackerman's and shifters
are the exception
they won't turn into titans when exposed
to this stuff which as connie noticed is
the same thing as ragako village where
the entire village's inhabitants were
turned into titans and this smoke method
obviously makes more sense than if
they've spent time injecting
every last person in the village with
titan serum
you might ask why don't they take anyone
else with them it was probably too late
to outrun the smoke everyone was exposed
and now it's only a matter of time
before they turn
so if they were on the flying titan
they'd simply turn into titans and turn
on everyone else there
thus pique has to say goodbye to her
family and we have to say goodbye to
connie and jon as well as gabby although
people probably don't care that much
about saying goodbye to her
i'm not sure what happens here with
seemingly falco activating the scream
which usually turns the infected into
titans was he taken control of in that
instance
or did it just happen to look like a
scream that remains to be seen but it is
weird
people don't turn immediately after it
but soon enough
we got a powerful and touching moment
between jean
and connie as they prepare for the end
and connie brings up
how they did end up saving the world
thanks to jean
this really is the game of thrones of
anime with the character deaths
although i'm sure tagantine will end
much more satisfactory but the point is
we've lost
so many people and now even jean and
connie too
and of course just as annie and her dad
are about to reunite
her dad along with everyone else turns
to a titan at the same time
and there are titans everywhere onyen
kopon
is not in good shape and it doesn't help
that all around him people are turning
into titans
luckily he is with annie so he's not all
alone still though how horrible is this
situation
just a little while ago the marlayan and
annie's dad were smiling and hopeful
of working together in peace and now we
see the merlion's face
and he is horrified as he looks at the
titans
do we really think that that horror will
let him spare the remaining eldians
if they somehow make it out of this
alive and if the marlenes have a chance
to kill them
again attack on time refuses to give us
any easy answers or solutions
the titans are clearly all being
controlled by the centipede creature
just like aaron was controlling titans
before so it is possible that this
creature might have used falco and made
him scream to transform the others the
problem with that though is why is the
creature letting armin and reiner fight
it then
if it can stop them as reiner points out
this creature
summoned a titan army and it attacks the
armored titan
although reiner says they're not getting
past him this dude was having trouble
before the titan army showed up
he's brave here but the situation is far
from hopeful
he even gets knocked around before we
jump to colossal armin vs colossal aaron
with hair
armin says he'll follow aaron until the
end which could very well mean
he's accepted aaron's plan to take all
the world's hatred on himself
before letting them finish him off
making his friends the heroes who saved
the world from the ultimate devil aaron
jaeger
reiner is again wrestling the centipede
but it's huge
and he can't really do anything we also
see titan connie jean and gabby along
with
some titan parents including reiner's
mom peak jumps down and transforms to
help reiner and
bites the creature and annie's female
titan is there too helping
in one panel we actually get to see them
fighting the centipede with all the
titans present
and armin and aaron fist fighting in the
background a pretty crazy scene
what a freaking action-packed chapter
this is probably the most
action-packed chapter in the entire
series keep in mind
even though it seems pointless to try to
kill this creature
it looks like they are succeeding in
slowing it down a bit
since its goal is to reconnect with
aaron the founding titan
and it keeps moving towards him with its
titan army
mikasa's head keeps hurting the most
it's ever hurt in one chapter that's for
sure
levi lets her know she's gotta get it
together since they're the only ones
that can kill aaron
remember that ackerman's are immune from
memory manipulation and
probably from being controlled by the
falling titan as well but
also the other titan shifters are all
busy with holding back the centipede too
mikasa's headache leads us into what
appears to be a dream
a what-if scenario as she wishes to go
back to her
and aaron's home we see a vision of them
living in peace in a cabin
and mikasa says she feels like she just
had a long dream
now in this reality alternate timeline
or whatever it is
our main story has been labeled a long
dream
the most fascinating question here is if
this is actually just as real in some
sense as our darkest timeline that we're
experiencing
or is it just pure fantasy i hope we get
more answers next chapter but isayama
may well leave it open for
interpretation the thing is we the
readers or at least
i wanted to see a happy ending for aaron
and mikasa and in this way isayama gave
us a sense of what that would look like
without actually changing the main
storyline we've been experiencing up to
this point
in this cabin world mikasa cries saying
she's not sure if she's supposed to be
here and aaron says that they can't do
anything about that since they abandoned
everything and ran away here
here it's been two months since the war
against marley ended and they'll
invade parody soon everyone would die if
they don't run
aaron assumes that armin is probably
looking for them here he couldn't decide
what path to take
so he just wanted to live out the rest
of his 4 years with mikasa peacefully
the interesting thing here is that this
is what king carl fritz decided to do
on a larger scale when he escaped to the
island and created the walls in the
first place
aaron hated that and yet here he decided
to take a similar course
interestingly enough this aaron wants
mikasa to promise that once aaron dies
she'll throw away the scarf he gave her
since she'll live
long after he's gone he wants her to
forget about him and be
free and that makes much more sense
coming from aaron compared to how he's
been acting to mikasa recently and it
seems that knowing he'd have to leave
anyway because of amir's curse
he said he hated mikasa so it'd be
easier for her to move on from him
at his core he wants what's best for
mikasa and in his mind that means her
being free of him
this could even possibly be mikasa and
aaron connecting through the paths
as aaron did before with the other
aldians i love to see them hugging
outside of that idyllic cottage house
they got going on
and it goes to show how many options we
have in life and how much different
our lives can be depending on the
decisions we make let me know your
thoughts
would it have been better if aaron had
chosen to go out like this
do you look at the 145th king's decision
to create
parody and await their deaths in peace
in a different light now
in many ways this cottage world would
have been an easier decision for aaron
to make
because he wouldn't have to undergo such
horrors himself but at the same time it
would have most likely meant
more horrors for parody island we then
jumped to aaron's colossal titan
punching armins in the face with his
hardened fists
you gotta love the hardened fists move
and if it even did damage on the armor
titan's face
you can bet it will do so on the less
defended colossal titan
reiner is being attacked as is peak and
annie
we'll see what happens here but if
things keep going like this
we may actually get jean connie and or
gabby turning back at the humans after
they consume one of these shifters
i'm hoping annie will survive and have
some sort of future with armin even if
it's short-lived and i can see gabby and
falco surviving together too
but reiner who's been fantasizing about
death may well die
unless isayama wants to keep trolling us
with the unbelievable luck of the plot
armored titan
it's ironic that this guy who keeps
wanting to die and keeps throwing
himself
in death's way keeps coming out of every
situation alive somehow so i honestly
wouldn't even be surprised if he makes
it out of this too
then we see mikasa refuse aaron's
request which although
it was delivered in that fantasy world
seems to convey aaron's true thoughts to
her in this world as well
she refuses to get rid of the scarf and
to forget about him
she actually tightens it around herself
and tells everyone else that she'll kill
aaron who's residing in the mouth of the
titan again
aaron might have communicated to her
that he's in the mouth
because he wants her to kill him so the
aliens will be thought of as the heroes
who stop the devil it's a team effort
and the core characters like armin and
levi
help mikasa get inside aaron's mouth now
that's a weird sentence
inside the mouth she sees aaron's head
there and smiles as she cuts it off
she says see you later aaron and we have
the two worlds overlapping here they
kiss in both the cottage world
and here where aaron's head has been
sliced off
and so we got the kiss we've been
begging for
for so long although definitely not in
the way we probably expected
and honestly something like this is
classic isayama you always have a darker
twist to the romance
but damn that was an impactful kiss i
had a really old video on youtube about
the top 10 most epic anime kisses of all
time
before i had to take it down due to
copyright reasons you know how youtube
works but this definitely would make it
into my revised list
i'm so glad we got this kiss because the
series has been tiptoeing around their
romantic feelings forever
so it's so nice to get something
conclusive here we're told to the boy
who sought freedom
goodbye so it is a goodbye kiss and even
emir is over here smiling and i'm sure
we'll have many of our questions
answered in the next and final
chapter like what's historia saying but
wow what a crazy climax this was to the
series
in the middle of all this horror we got
such a romantic moment
shakespeare would be proud you
definitely got some romeo and juliet
vibes here
since even romeo and juliet both kiss
the other when they were dead
or thought they were dead and sorry for
those romeo and juliet spoilers but back
to attack on titan
why is amir smiling does she love seeing
the good side of humanity
or does that smile have something to do
with the possibility that if the fouling
titan dies without the centipede in it
she may finally be free and does have to
roam in the other world for the rest of
eternity we'll find out but she wanted
freedom from her enslaved existence
she wanted something to change so if
she's smiling that might mean she's
gotten what she wished for this chapter
was also a really huge run for mikasa
where she proved once and for all that
she wasn't a slave who had to protect
aaron
at all costs and she did that by slicing
off his head
clearly that is the opposite of
protecting someone and ironically even
though she was willing to kill him she
refused to stop
loving him as he wanted her too talk
about your complicated love stories
by killing the one she loved she proved
that she loved him out of free will and
not
out of some brainwashed ackerman thing
can't wait to find out
more about everything in the next
chapter although you gotta expect that
isayama like many others
could well leave a lot of things
ambiguous and open to interpretation
nevertheless this is a great chapter
and probably the most romantic one
despite the tragic circumstances that is
it for this one and we only have one
more chapter to go
people let me know if you loved this one
or hated it and what you want from the
final
chapter ever i did my first attack a
time chapter review almost four years
ago now
and it's crazy to think how far the
story has come since then and how far
the channel has come since then too
thank you guys for being along for this
crazy amazing ride
and i hope you'll join me next month
when i cover
in probably a bittersweet way the final
chapter ever
of attack on titan it's tragic that our
protagonist seems to be gone for good
but i think we all predicted that would
be the outcome and having accepted that
i'm so glad we got that kiss before it
was all over
if you did enjoy this review and got
some value from it make sure the
warhammer smash that like button until
it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell
so you'll be notified when the final
chapter drops and while you wait a month
for the next and final chapter feel free
to check out our colossal attack on time
playlist with videos about the titan
shifters the ackermans the times ranked
for weakest the strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description remember just because the
manga is ending doesn't mean the attack
on time discussion
has to stop and it definitely will keep
going on this
channel and i especially want to thank
the patron squad over on patreon and
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged
by lord tuigo himself and the most
donated champion
of the world alpha sigma and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans in grotto the world acquire
respect but they have a liam thompson
alger tall
dr kortman johnny boy draws emperor
otaku
spidey life tinel baked buddhist and
tungsten tarkis
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
anatoly kozlowski joe stanton barry
gucci jessica kayla fond
rethuen de ora elisha actor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted note head deadly saint matthew
cruz and anthony schreiber
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work
you can support more of it by going over
to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord
where we talk about anime life waifus
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime upload link to that is in the
description if you're interested you can
also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue drawing
button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already clicked so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way you support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you